you
this is about the Fed feeling of
collectivity or this sort of shared
feeling this is about something bigger
than just being in that space looking at
this work of art when you see water
falling you also see time passing and
when you see time passing you see a
different kind of space what a waterfall
can do is add an element of temporal
quality and element of inclusivity and
element for possibility to share an
experience a shared space
it's a great thing if you can somehow
combine singularity and collectivity the
presence of other people in the piece
plays a central role for your experience
what is it that makes a space you know
challenging and exciting and embracing
and including and hospitable and
intolerant and so on what is that
about ten years ago I had an exhibition
Herto tape called the weather project
where I had something like a very big
Sun in the turbine hole it also became
about the people which were in the space
and about the feeling of being in that
space now for a while been working on an
idea for work of art which is this
little thing here I call it little Sun
solar panel a container light on the
other side I charge it for hours of
charging gives you five hours of line
most people who don't have energy they
rely on cable scene or lightning Kira
scene of courses unhealthy this one is
ten times cheaper than killing it has
ten times more line which gives you a
hundred times better performance latest
social light is life
this is about strength and about power
and about energy but happiness and love
but that's the same for everybody this
is energy for all
you